isn't it right good evening everybody
for the second time
welcome to today's meeting of the
cabinet both those who are participating
and those who are watching on the live
stream
if members have technical difficulties
during the meeting then please contact
the democratic services officer on call
who will attempt to assist you
and on call today is katie brewer her
number is 577046
and it will also be at the top of the
chat thread for members if you need it
for those of you watching by the
council's youtube stream please follow
the instructions
below the video if there are any issues
with the live feed
i'd ask participants when you're not
speaking please mute your microphone
this minimizes background noise and will
help everybody in listening to the
proceedings
microphones must only be on if the
participant has been granted permission
to speak
to gain my permission to speak please
very briefly indicate on the chat to the
right side of the screen
and i will then make a note and go back
to you once the person speaking has
finished
please note that we'll be following the
usual cabinet protocols in which other
members of the council usually only
speak once
on each item and by giving notice at the
start of the meeting
so everybody please ensure their mobile
phones are turned to silent that they're
not used to make or receive phone calls
while the meeting's in progress
please also refrain from
checking emails or conducting other
business and ensure that you're in a
quiet room free from distractions for
the duration of the meeting
as we've noted the meeting is being live
streamed for members of the public it
will also be recorded and subsequently
made available on the internet
so can i uh please ask members of the
cabinet to confirm that they're present
when i read out their name and i'll ask
members
uh i'll ask that the attendance of those
counselors are participating uh
to speak under council procedure rule
twenty point one separately
first we'll cast the white head
councillor sorry yeah
sequence for some reason councillor why
ahead but never mind that's that's your
strengths as deputy leader i think
counselor album yes i'm here councillor
duckworth
here and council yates present chat
thank you um the following members have
asked to speak under council procedure
rule 20.1 when i say your name
can you please confirm that you're
present in the meeting council
here chair thank you uh councillor jill
bayford
here jim and councillor pugh
here chair thank you are there any other
councillors present that wish to speak
and the council procedure rule 20.1
no they don't appear to be so we move on
to the main business of the meeting so
there are no apologies
do we have any declarations of interest
in items of business on the agenda this
evening members
i'm not seeing any thank you so the next
item is the minutes of the previous
meeting
and cabinet's asked to approve the
summary of recommendations and decisions
at the cabinet meeting held on the 22nd
of october
copy which was attached to the agenda
pack um i'll propose
the minutes is there a second yeah i'll
second it chair
seconded by councillor album unless i
hear any objection
i'll take these minutes as approved
thank you that's agreed and item 4
is the cabinet response to the to
adequate toilet facilities that fanuc
beaches petition
and that's one for you councillor album
it certainly is chair and uh good
evening members and good evening to any
residents who are
watching um
a petition was received in uh june 2020
with 147 valid signatures
the petition reads we the undersigned
petition the council to hold a thorough
review
of the facilities available around the
thanet beaches
to ensure the safety and well-being of
both visitors
and residents and to invest in adequate
infrastructure to meet the outcome
in accordance with uh council's
constitution
this petition was reported to council
without debate on the 9th of july of
this year
at present uh there are 28 toilets open
during the summer months
13 are on or near to beaches
and are fundamental in achieving uh our
blue flag stasis
a minimum of 16 toilets uh
normally remain open all year round
the pandemic presented significant
challenges this summer
following the relaxation of the national
lockdown in may
additional temporary toilets were
provided
both at margate and botany bay
the temporary toilets and kovid 19
measures
had a big impact on the
limited budget of toilet
provision
uh i propose
that cabinet adopt motion one
and note the concerns raised in the
petition
and respond to confirm
that toilet facilities serving thani
beaches
will be reviewed both by officers
and members over the winter season
with the review and recommendations to
be reported back to cabinet
in march 2021
i would also advise that the decision of
this cabinet
will be reported to council on the 10th
of december
2020. thank you councillor alban
um you've moved that i'll second that
and councillor cup
can come in thank you chair and thank
you uh councillor album for uh
reading that out to us all i was just uh
i wanted to
say i'm firstly happy that the decision
has been
taken to take forward option one on this
um
i was wondering if it is possible to
re-engage
and re-initiate the the toilet review
group
um that was initially put in place under
the previous administration
um of the council because i feel as if
this is a decision that
can be brought about and reviewed under
a cross-party measure and i think by
having the
review group back in place it would
ensure that that is um done so and to
make sure there is
a fair say from members across all
wards um and and secondly just
if i may quickly uh chair in the uh
budget that was agreed in uh
february 2020 um in that item
agenda item six i believe it was um
section 8.4
it said that there was a budget put
aside to ensure that
there was going to be a creation of 10
new environmental operatives
now i was just wondering whether or not
those operatives and those posts
have actually been filled thank you
thank you council cup i'm not sure how
relevant that is to the petition of
radical toilet facilities at sanic
beaches but i'll let
councillor album respond yeah
thank you chair uh yeah thank you
council cup um
no i i don't think that the last matter
you raised has got anything to do with
the toilets and um
and i i and i'm not gonna answer that um
but certainly uh i i think
what what you're proposing is uh is
something that we should
consider uh you're quite right i uh
that a cross-party agreement
um would be a possible way
way forward and i'm more than happy to
review that with the rest of the cabinet
and um and corporate management team
thank you thank you councillor alban and
i think um
in response i think all members across
the council recognize that the public
toilets
are an important service that we provide
to our residents
and there's something in which residents
take a great interest their availability
and as councillors it's beholden on us
to do the same and we do
particularly in the areas that we
represent so i'm sympathetic to the idea
that there is the widest possible member
involvement in those decisions
ultimately of course a lot of it does
come down to money and
that's in short supply um not unusually
so is there any further debate on that
i'm not seeing any other members who
wish to speak on it
um so members should we take that as
agreed
agreed agree thank you thank you we move
on to
item five which is the mid-year review
2021
treasury management and annual
investment strategy with council yates
thank you jeff this report summarizes
treasury management activity
and treasury indicators the first half
of 2020 to 21
no difficulties are envisioned for the
current year and complying with the
indicators
the report also sets out a revision in
the 2020-21 treasury management strategy
to amend the minimum credit rating of
counterparties from a
to a minus for specific investments the
change will help the councils continue
to manage its investments effectively
given the actual and potential economic
impact of factors such as the
coronavirus pandemic and brexit
i move the recommendations thank you
councillor yates i'll second that
any member wish to comment
no so members would take that as agreed
unless i hear any objections
thank you item six is the policy for
imposing financial penalties under the
electrical safety standards in the
private
rented sector england regulations 2020.
and council of whitehead is going to
make that sound more interesting than
the tight title does i think
i'll do my best um
thank you very much chair
ensuring that fanuc residents have safe
secure housing
whether within the council or as private
residents is a huge priority to this
council
in bringing our housing service back
in-house we took a very significant step
to show our priorities as a direct
landlord
with the onset of new legislation we are
extending protections into the private
sector
as the local housing authority we have a
statutory duty to enforce the electrical
safety standards in the private rented
sector
england regulations 2020
these new regulations require private
landlords to maintain electrical safety
standards in privately rented homes
this is a new legal requirement and one
which has long been overdue
in terms of our approach as a council
and as a department
this signifies the importance of
accommodation as a whole
across both council and privately rented
properties
and it takes an important step towards
showing tenants that we as a council
have expectations of private landlords
in terms of the safety and treatment of
their tenants
much as we expect the highest standards
of our service and work constantly
towards fully fulfilling low veins
these regulations have applied to all
new tenancies since the 1st of june 2020
and will apply to all existing tenancies
from the 1st of april 2021
the principal requirements of the
legislation are as follows
landlords must ensure that a suitably
competent and qualified person
inspects and tests their electrical
installations at intervals of not more
than five years
and must ensure that all repairs needed
to make their installation safe
are carried out the council will act as
the enforcing authority
and we must be ready to enforce the
regulations when landlords do not meet
their statutory responsibilities
are set out under regulation for
the health and safety of our tenants
depends on their accommodation
not all housing is under direct control
but regulations such as these allow us
to extend protections to the private
sector
and ensure that all residents who are
reliant on property rental are protected
under regulation 11 when in the public
interest it will sometimes be
appropriate for the council to impose a
financial penalty penalty
of up to 30 000 pounds on a
non-compliant private landlord
government guidance requires the council
to develop and document a policy
which sets out the level of financial
penalty it should impose in each case
having regard to the severity of the
breach
the prescribed procedural requirements
are set out in schedule two to the
regulations
and the proposed policy are next to this
report has been developed in accordance
with this guidance
careful regard has been taken of the
relevant legislation and government
guidance in the prep
words preparation of our proposed policy
for imposing financial penalties
the regulations both impose duty's
honest and authority
and give us powers to enforce our
obligations
under these regulations we are under a
duty to serve a remedial notice where we
have reasonable grounds to believe that
a private landlord
is in breach of one or more of the
duties imposed by the regulations
the remedial notice will specify the
remedial action necessary
and require that the action be completed
within 28 days
a private landlord may make written
representations against such notice
within 21 days
in addition we have power to arrange a
remedial action
if a private landlord does not comply
with the remedial notice
the lha has the power with the tenants
consent to undertake the remedial action
specified in the notice
and recover the costs incurred from the
private landlord
we also have power to undertake urgent
remedial action
where a report indicates that urgent
remedial action is required
and the private landlord does not take
time reaction the lha may with the
tenants consent undertake the urgent
remedial action and recover the costs
incurred
finally as previously referenced we have
a power to impose a financial penalty
if we are satisfied beyond reasonable
doubt that a private landlord has
breached a duty under the regulations
we have the power to impose a financial
penalty of up to 30 000 pounds
it is important that fines are
proportionate and recognize the severity
of the breach
our approach has been designed to align
with our previously adopted
policy for imposing financial penalties
under the housing act 2004
and housing and planning act 2016 which
was adopted by cabinet on the 14th
march 2019 and also follows mhclg
guidance
in relation to the proportionality of
penalties taking note of the following
factors
the severity of the offence the
culpability and track record of the
offender
the harm caused to the tenant both
actual and potential
whether the penalty is proportionate to
the offence and has a real economic
impact
whether it will deter the offender from
repeating the offence
whether it will deter others from
committing similar offences
whether it will remove any financial
benefit the offender may have
obtained as a result of committing the
events any monies collected through
financial penalties must be ring fenced
by the council
and will only be used to fund private
sector housing enforcement activities
to ensure that penalties go towards
ensuring a greater standard of safety
across the private sector
unsafe electrical installations can
greatly increase the risk of electric
shock and fire
and so it is imperative that the council
robustly enforces the regulations to
safeguard residents living in the
private rented sector
tenants deserve safety and protection
whether we are the landlord or whether
it is a private tenancy
i welcome this legislation and also
welcome a significant step forward
in terms of guaranteed parity of care
within the private sector
i propose the recommendations set out in
the report
thank you councillor whitehead and i'll
second that um
and i just comment that i i really
welcome
this policy in terms of enforcement
against the private rented sector
because we know that that is a
significant sector in thanet
and whilst this is quite a a dry
document and a technical document it is
a very important matter
and i'll call in councillor jill
bakewood thank you chair
i also welcome the introduction of this
policy as
tenant safety is paramount i've just one
question
relating to enforcement where it's
stated that in the event of a financial
penalty remaining unpaid
this council can make application for a
property owned by the offender to be
sold
could this create a situation where a
tentative property would be sold
rendering a tenant homeless and there
being one less property available for
rental in the private sector
thank you councillor why how do you want
to respond to that
yeah thank you very much for that
question it's a very pertinent one
um we would always consider the impact
of the tenant in a situation such as
this
so not only do we have to consider
tenant safety
um we also have to consider the overall
impact on the tenant
so that is something that is
incorporated within
our fee structure and within the policy
in terms of how we choose to proceed
um but i'd like to bring in mr hopkins
in relation to
how we would deal with that situation
specifically
thank you
hello yeah thanks um what
the policy is setting out is that we
will use all the potential powers that
we have to reclaim the financial
penalties
obviously a financial penalty uh if
imposed you know it's very important
that we do pursue it
so one of the potential options a
potentially extreme option
is that we can apply for an interim
charging order against the property
owned by the landlord
what that does is put a charge against
the property and that
usually would be uh something that would
convince the person
uh subject to the penalty to actually
pay it it would only be an
extreme uh case where we would go on
and ask for the courts to to allow a
court order for the property to be sold
that doesn't necessarily mean that the
tenant would lose their property because
it may be sold with attendance
tenant in in situ thank you very much
thank you thank you mr hopkins um so
that's been moved and seconded members
i'm not seeing any further comments so
unless i hear any objections i'll take
those recommendations
as approved for submission to council
thank you and we move on to item seven
which is the budget
monitoring number 2 2021 and that's
councillor yates again
thank you chair this report is the
second budget monitoring report for this
year
it focuses on the general fund it
forecasts the gross overspend of 5.2
million pounds
largely as a result of additional costs
and lost income because of covert
this compares to a forecast overspend of
5.6 million pounds
in the first budget monitoring report
this current forecast was
prepared before considering the
financial implications of the second
national lockdown government emergency
funding sport covered amounts to 2.9
million pounds so far
additionally there is a commitment to
cover 75 of lost income from fees and
charges
although this is subject to a five
percent top slice and does not include
commercial income
this is estimated at eight hundred
thousand pounds giving total estimated
government funding of three point seven
million pounds
the first monitoring report estimated
government covered funding
would be 2.6 million pounds which
resulted in the council deciding on the
10th of september to utilize 3 million
pounds of reserves
now the net overspend after the
additional covered funding is smaller
but we also in in the second national
lockdown so
a further report will be prepared to
consider how to manage reserves
in advance of that it is recommended
that 200 000 pounds be transferred from
the covered shortfall reserve
to the equalization reserve this
reflects the yield from an anticipated
council tax increase
which will help fund a 21 to 22 budget
gap
and is assumed in the budget strategy
report on this agenda
the general fund capital programme is
showing a substantial understand
this again is largely due to covert as
works contracts
have been hampered and suppliers have
been unable to deliver within the normal
time scales
it is planned for most capital projects
to catch up during the next financial
year
i moved the recommendations thank you
councillor yates um i'll second the
recommendations
um and councillor pugh wishes to speak
thank you chair um yeah councillor it's
just a specific question
particularly on um section 2.2
subsection 6
on your leisure and the associated uh
potential overspend of about 160 000
pounds
um you know i understand that your
leisure is struggling as are many
companies
in a similar situation at the moment
similar companies and i completely get
that
um and i appreciate that we won't really
know the full picture until
we come out of the lockdown and
everything but considering we paid the
maintenance fee
up front 160 000 pounds fine uh that's
the way it is but
if your leisure doesn't come out at the
other end of the lot down
in a better position or doesn't survive
god forbid it goes under what are our
associated costs and risks
as a council that could potentially
impact on our budget
and a lot of our revenue and what
liabilities do we have towards
your leisure the staff any other kind of
aspects like that that particularly
could
you know essentially blow any
forecasting that we have completely out
of the water
thank you council blue council yates
yes thank you council pew and um i think
we'd all agree that
it's in the council's interest and make
sure that um
your leisure especially the leisure
centers are kept running for the
residents of thailand
um the one of the key points
here is that there is some national
government funding
uh i believe there's um around
100 million pounds which has been
allocated towards
um councils with leisure centers
um and we're waiting to get the detail
from that
um to understand how much your leisure
will be getting so there is support
um during this time for your leisure um
as to the full kind of
like risks of your leisure not being in
a good position
after covered i think that would require
that's not something i can tell you
right
right now but i'm happy to provide you
uh
with an email or we can set up a meeting
to discuss that further
um because i think that would take quite
a while to
uh run through um and i'm happy
to just uh bring in mr willis at this
point
in case he's got anything to add on that
thank you council lakes uh thanks chair
um i
all i would add to that is um i mean the
question um from council
pew in essence was what if your leisure
doesn't survive
um what would be the consequences and i
can certainly provide an answer
subsequent to this meeting um to that
specific question
that i would just concur with council
yates that
we hope that we that doesn't come to
pass and the council is doing what it
can to avoid that coming to pass
and there with there is a planned
cabinet report a future date
to deal with these issues regarding your
leisure
thank you mr willis um and and i just
add to that the
um cabinet and officers are very aware
of the
situation with your leisure and there is
a i know that mr willis is in constant
dialogue with your leisure so
um it's not something that we're
blindsided by we are well aware
um obviously there's a problem for the
leisure industry in general
and of the risk to this council so
something we can explore further
um right so that's been moved and
seconded is there any further discussion
on this subject doesn't appear to be so
members should i take that
budget monitoring report recommendations
as approved
that's why i hear anything i'm not
hearing the objections so we move on to
item eight
which is another long title the policy
for imposing financial and publication
penalties under the energy efficiency
private rented property england and
wales regulations
2015 and council of whitehead's going to
do another splendid job explaining that
one
i have the best titles
as part of our ongoing duties towards
tenants the council has a statutory duty
to enforce the energy efficiency
private rented property england and
wales regulations 2015
in respect of domestic private rented
property
the regulations have since the 1st of
april 2020
prohibited private landlords from
renting out homes that are subject to an
energy performance certificate
with an energy efficiency rating of f or
g
the regulations were made to help ensure
that those private tenants
in most need of more thermally efficient
homes particularly vulnerable people and
the fuel poor
are able to enjoy a more comfortable and
healthier living environment
and lower energy bills they are also
part of the wider strategy to reduce
uk greenhouse gas emissions and align
with our overall aims as a council to
both safeguard vulnerable tenants
and promote energy efficiency
persons from vulnerable groups can
sometimes have limited housing choices
in particular families with young
children older persons and those with a
disability can find themselves in poor
quality
privately rented accommodation that
lacks adequate provision
for insulation and space heating
consequently the council's enforcement
activities often involve safeguarding
the health
safety and welfare of persons with the
protected characteristics of age and
disability
enhanced enforcement capabilities
provided by financial penalties
will help to minimize disadvantage and
contribute to addressing the needs of
many residents with protected
characteristics
in late 2019 the council successfully
submitted a bid
to the government's prs innovation and
enforcement fund
2019-20 in the sum of 34
742 pounds the bid was entitled
planet called homes finder a project to
proactively identify privately rented
homes
which have an energy performance
certificate epc rating of f-4g
the original project was intended to
last for 10 weeks until the end of march
2020
but was extended owing to the kovid 19
pandemic
since january 2020 the council has been
working hard to identify privately
rented homes with an f org rating
we initially contacted 3400 properties
to explain the new regulations and
requirements
by july 390 target properties remained
all 390 properties were contacted and 90
contacts were made by landlords
we have encouraged many landlords to
upgrade their properties
but there are some homes which remain
substandard
it is therefore important that the
council proactively enforces the
regulations
to improve the conditions for the
tenants living in those homes
when in the public interest it will
sometimes be appropriate for the council
to impose a financial
and or publication penalty on a
non-compliant landlord
there are four breaches of the
regulations that can attract financial
penalty
with the maximum amount payable in
respect of any one tenancy
being 5000 pounds
the council has developed a policy which
sets out the level of financial penalty
it should impose
in respect of each type of breach
the policy also includes the provision
to impose a publication penalty
with every financial penalty issued
any monies collected through financial
penalties may be retained by the council
improving the energy efficiency of homes
in the private rented sector in planet
will help us not only protect tenants
reduce fuel bills and further extend
private sector protections
but it will also help us to play our
part in reducing greenhouse gas
emissions
and align us with the aims of our
declared climate emergency
i propose the recommendations set out in
the report
thank you councillor whitehead i'll
second that and that's another important
issue
councillor jill bayford thank you chair
i totally support this policy in that
people in vulnerable groups are
protected through enhanced safeguarding
and provided with a healthier living
environment
with reference to point seven point
three it's stated that under the sunny
cold homes find
project by july 300 and sorry by july
390 target properties from the original
3400
were contacted by the only 90 responses
were received
now that the project is completed how
will the remaining 300
properties be addressed thank you
councillor beauford uh
council whitehead yeah in respect to the
390 properties
um we've made sure that we have contact
details
for those landlords which how the
initial contact was made
those that we haven't heard from
obviously we have the contact details
in order to maintain that contact advise
them
what changes need to be made and advise
them how they can best
do that if those landlords still remain
non-compliant
the policy sets out exactly how we can
enforce
changes and how we can enforce the
changes that are needed within the
property to make sure that tenants stay
safe
but i'm happy to refer to mr hopkins for
any specifics of what we're doing in
respect of those landlords remaining
thank you
hello there yeah um so uh
like all legislative um processes that
we enforce
uh there's usually a graduate graduating
response so
what we've done is um well the
government helped
pay well paid for all the land registry
searches we needed for all of these
properties so we have
uh that information which is final and
conclusive as to ownership
uh they've all had letters um and
they've been told informally that they
must meet the regulations
um once this policy if it's if it's
approved
is in place then we'll be issuing
compliance notices on those that we
identify as being non-compliant
and that will require them to provide us
with evidence
uh about the property the epc
certificate tenancies and stuff like
that
if they don't comply with that
compliance notice they can be subject to
a penalty
and ultimately uh if that doesn't
encourage them
uh to to to raise the standard then
the next step would be that the penalty
notice and then
uh potentially a financial penalty of uh
four thousand pounds in addition
so it's a case of if they don't register
a valid exemption they will eventually
be subject to enforcement action
thank you thank you mr hopkins um
no other member wishes to speak on that
item so unless i hear any objection i'll
take it that those recommendations have
been approved
so that's approved we move on to item 9
which is the 2021 budget strategy
and back to council yates thank you
chair
this report sets the framework for the
21 to 22 budget
it explains the backdrop to the budget
including the uncertainty surrounding
government policy regarding local
government finance
it also outlines the internal challenges
when setting phanet's budget
the budget gap is projected to be eight
and eight hundred and forty thousand
pounds
the budget gap represents a difference
between the council's planned
expenditure
and the level of funding available
cabinet is well advanced in identifying
how the budget gap will be addressed
but this report does not include those
proposals these will be included in the
budget report to cabinet in january
and council in february the 840 000
pound gap assumes the fees and charges
will be increased by two percent
and the council agrees a council tax
increase of two percent
if these were not to be agreed the gap
would be 1.24 million pounds
the composition of the budget gap is set
sour in section three of the report
you can see that the additional costs
are largely unavoidable
it is worth pointing out that the
current budget gaps of other local
authorities are great deal larger than
thanets
the reasons for this will be varied
including according to local issues
i believe is at least in part because
danny's finances are well managed
i think we can all pause to recognize
this and it's testament to sensible
decision making of all members
informed by the sound advice of the
staff
cabinet will be recommending the budgets
council in the new year once further
information is available from the
government we're committed to
transparency throughout the process
and i hope members have valued the
briefings briefings today
and will take advantage of the briefings
of smaller groups of members
once we're in a position to do so we
shall share our thinking and plans with
the public
we are also asking residents about their
views in the annual resident survey
the findings from these surveys along
with the council's stated priorities
will continue to inform cabinet's
recommended budget
i move the recommendations thank you
council yates and i'm happy to second
those recommendations and uh
just to say that i'm pleased that we've
already started uh
an inclusive process of consulting
members across the council about the
budget um i know that there have been
a small group meeting there's been a
small group meeting with mr willis today
of
cross party members and also we've had a
briefing with shadow cabinet
and i hope that this is going to be a
constructive process in which we can
work together now clearly
shadow cabinet have not brought forward
anything to say tonight but there'll be
plenty of other opportunities during the
process
um to talk about the budget and i'm sure
that we'll have some
useful and constructive exchanges on the
way to
budget council in the new year so
unless i hear any objections i will take
that recommendations approved members
that's fine thank you and we move on to
item 10 which is the fees and charges
and this one's correctly titled 2021-22
because i think the title of the last
one was wrong on my script
council yates thank you jeff a review of
fusion charges has now been completed as
part of the 21-22 budget setting process
as referred to in the budget strategy
the proposed fees and charges are
expected to generate additional income
of around 200 000 pounds which
represents an average increase of 2
percent
subject to cabinet approval the schedule
of fees set out in the annex for this
report will be recommended to council
for decision on the 10th of december
and move the recommendations thank you
council yes i'm happy to second that
um and again there'll be further
opportunities to discuss these at
council
so unless i hear any objection i will
take it that those recommendations have
been approved
thank you so that's approved and we move
on to our
final item of business this evening
which is the waste disposal proposed
inter authority agreement and it's time
for councillor albert
i've got all the good ones um
right thank you chair um as members are
aware
thanick district council is the waste
collection authority
the household waste uh kent county
council is the waste disposal
authority uh then district council
entered an inter-authority
agreement with kent county council in
2010
as part of the east kent waste
partnership
regarding disposal of household and
street waste
the agreement includes enabling payments
which are made by kent county council to
thanet district council
to support the delivery of the current
curbside
collection service the payment is based
on
anticipated recycling performance
and savings generated by diverting waste
from landfill the existing agreement
will expire on the 15th of january
2021 with no option for an extension
a new agreement is therefore required to
allow
fanuc district council to continue to
receive the benefit of enabling payments
based on recycling performance
a new agreement has been drafted with a
proposed
five-year term that's a three years with
a two-year
extension option the current agreement
was between
four authorities and kent county council
however east kent authorities will
negotiate separately
for new agreements the new agreement
will not affect waste collection and
have no impact
on residents
there are three options listed in the
report
however i propose that cabinet support
option one
for cabinet to agree that the director
of operations
in consultation with finance and legal
colleagues
shall agree the final terms of a new
inter-authority agreement with kent
county council with a duration of five
years
commencing from the 16th of january 2021
for the disposal of the waste streams
listed
in annex one of the report including
household waste
thank you chair thank you
councillor album so you're moving um
option one and i'm seconding that
um i've got no speakers on that so
unless i hear
from anybody i should assume that that
is agreed
that seems to be agreed member so that
concludes the business for tonight's
meeting
i declare the meeting closed at uh 1808
thank you to everyone who participated
both members and officers
and to those watching from home the live
stream of the meeting will now
end and i wish you all a good evening
thank you